[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh bubba watson two-time masters
champ the ambassador for the
award-winning golf clash
the number one grossing sports mobile
game in the united states
and the uk with more than 90 million
global
downloads and uh there's a new version
of the official
bubba ball his very own custom golf ball
themed
nine hole cup tournament and uh the
themed bubba tea bubble hole
now there's a lot a lot going on here
with bubba watson
who joins us on the program before we
talk about that bubba
if you were going to play 18 holes at
augusta
and you could only have one club which
one would you choose
seven iron have you done it before
not at augusta i've played a lot of golf
with one club i played with every club
in my bag
um even a putter just to see just to try
it and then uh
i i just enjoy having fun with the golf
at a golf course so uh
seven iron's the best club though why is
that
you can you can hook it you can cut it
hit low high but you can still manage to
get out of a bunker
if you need to um and you can still play
bumping runs around the green
i just feel like that's the most
versatile club
have you ever like can you show up
unannounced to augusta
and play um
i don't know because i always announce
but but you haven't been with your guys
and then you say you know what
let's just get in the car and we'll
drive down to augusta no
i'm taking guests i have to call and um
have a member with me
um even though the member is like uh
we'll say a chaperone
yeah um and i still have to pay for him
and his caddy and
uh and all those things but um
if i came by myself i would still let
them know just to give them a heads up
but i haven't been here by myself i
always bring a guest or two and what
what do green fees cost it's a great
question
i've been very i've been very blessed
and i haven't checked the bill out in
many many years wait so you don't know
what they put on your tab
it does it's it's it's augusta national
man you just play it
you'll figure out the details later do
you have two green jackets
i have one they they they give you the
same one you know
but you've wanted twice i've won it
twice yes
well that's unfair you should be able to
have one there and one at home
listen i'm not going to argue okay give
me the one i'm good
okay but maybe a green robe or something
like a master's green robe for home
what do you think if you know of a good
road place maybe i'll just get one made
i got a robe guy he makes them for
boxers
put bubba on the i'm sure your wife
would love that you have bubba on the
back
your big green robe there uh how i
always
and look being a weekend warrior you go
from being on the range and you're like
killing it like you're unbelievable that
walk
from the range to the first tee at
augusta like have you had one of those
moments where you're great on the range
not good on the course and vice versa oh
we all had that yeah
we um the golf is so mental you know i
mean it's
physical is what we always say is what
10 90 mental um
and yeah you can you can get in your own
way um as we've seen golfers especially
myself
i've got my own way a lot over the years
but what happens
like how do you explain that where that
that
walk is not that far but it feels like
it's a long distance away when you're
not playing well
it's so it's a four-letter word it's
called golf um
and we it some reason we keep signing up
for it
it makes us so mad and then we come back
and do it again
i don't know that's a great question and
we challenge ourselves every day trying
to
get better what's it like when you want
to hide out there
luckily in the champions locker room you
can hide pretty good
but when you get on the course and
you're not playing well and
in your mind you're trying to work on
things and but you still got to play
yeah you're hoping that somebody else is
tearing the golf course up so they're
filming them and not you
uh explain to me what you're doing with
golf clash
yeah it's the best game on the uh on any
app right now
um golf clash is just a fun game to uh
to waste some time to play against
buddies and an easy way to do it
and you know we started a nine hole
challenge
i got my own tournament now in golf
clash i got a special bubba tea
um you know we still have the one hole
challenge
one shot challenge and um so we just
kind of doctored it up made it a little
bit better
and you know it's something fun for me
to do some of my friends do
and i've actually played with my son a
little bit um so it's a it's a fun time
and uh
and a fun thing to do is augustus set up
for left-handers
um i don't know jack nicklaus did pretty
well being right-handed
uh i think six six times he won
tigers got i think five now yeah um
so lefties are are getting better i
think we're understanding the course a
little more
and then seeing uh mike weir and phil
mickelson win
it obviously uh gave us hope um and then
i've won
a couple of times and then and lefties
are growing there's more lefties play
and there were some kids
yesterday the age 12 and 13 boys
yesterday
there was four kids in that one age
group uh that were left-handed so i
think the lefties are coming out of the
woodwork more and more
companies are making better equipment
for lefties and um
there's gonna be more lefties so i guess
it'll equal out at some point
you know lefty's winning here as much as
righties when you were growing up
just because you're left-handed did you
feel like
you were different or did people make
you feel different
um i think people make me feel different
it wasn't really i mean i just played
golf i just play sports
i'm left-handed in all avenues of sports
and
um so yeah it's really just people ask
me
about being left-handed i didn't really
think about it i just played
hey but whatever makes me stand out i'm
good with it can you play right-handed
yes but worse than you oh
seriously if we played for money and and
you played right-handed i played
what i normally am right-handed yeah i
mean i could play
i can uh i could shoot you know i'd be
considered a hacker or
or one day a week guy but you know if i
practice i could probably get a little
bit better at it
well you know that i've played augusta
twice bubba
no i did not know that yeah man i'm so
excited yeah
um 83 first day 81 81 next uh the next
day
right here yeah you'd definitely beat me
if i was right-handed yeah but i also
had uh the caddy who caddied for sevy
and he said i'm going to tell you where
to hit it and do not question me
and he saved me 10 shots i'm going to
guess because people i
when you get to the greens like you guys
make it look really
easy or easier you get to those greens
and you're like oh my god
like i have no idea how to read how long
did it take for you to feel comfortable
where you kind of knew what to do and
when to do it
i'm still not comfortable you know it's
funny in november
a few months ago the golf course played
tremendously different
it was slower um the fairways were a
little softer
so it was it it changed everything we
know about the course um and if it rains
in the forecast it changes everything we
know about the course and so
we're always learning but yes there's
putts that um
you cannot believe um that break a
certain way and you're like there's no
way it breaks that way i've had a few
putts like that where i'm like
there's no way i can trust this and so
you miss those putts and you try to uh
not three-putt and also people don't
realize the the
the uh undulation with the green and
also there's there's a lot of hills
there
like you know there there's more of that
climb than you really think it feels
like it's flat but it's not
yeah every shot is it's like you're on a
slope every shot is um
a side hill lie and so you're trying to
uh
you know your swing's trying to
compensate for that trying to make the
ball go a certain way it makes it very
difficult with the the slope of the
fairways do you got your watch on right
now
always how many of those do you have
man um well you have too many if you
don't know how many you have bubba
well i've given away i've given away
about five
um so i think i got 13 maybe 15 at the
house
so those are you only have two wrists i
mean
it's you know you got to coordinate it
with your outfit you know like you know
you gotta you gotta match this up it's
like these it's like these rappers you
know they're rapping about watches you
know
i have them
and and who is it richard milley is that
it's richard mille yes oh i i screwed up
both of those names that's why
i'm not in that tax bracket where i can
afford that i can get the
paddock philippe but uh i can't get
richard mill
mill yeah exactly yeah uh hey great to
talk to you
good luck with uh the app there it's
called golf clash and we've been talking
to bubba watson uh have fun this week
and thanks for joining us
thanks for having me man thank you have
a good day that's boba watson